Now I know that this last method that we used might have felt a little bit
tedious, and it definitely is a fair amount of work, but for certain equations,
it's not too bad to work with. I think that it also really underscores exactly
how you get from the original expression you have to the factored form. It also
really highlights the connection between the different terms in each factor in
the factored form. And how they connect back to the original expression. So even
if you always factor by grouping from here on out this still a good experience
to have had. It's your choice and frankly both methods do use some similar
reasoning. You're still thinking about what numbers add to equal the middle
coefficient, and multiply it to equal the product of the two outer coefficients.